russian president vladimir putin as
mentioned was among the few world
leaders who attended the opening
ceremony of the winter olympics in
beijing he was seen watching ukrainian
athletes as russian forces appear to be
moving closer to potentially mounting a
full-scale invasion of ukraine president
biden is sending thousands of u.s troops
to eastern europe as a show of force
this as european allies ramp up their
push for diplomacy scheduling meetings
with putin and ukrainian president
zielenski next week christina raffini
has the very latest from the white house
christina good morning
good morning dana well the lighthouse is
lit up behind me in honor of america's
olympic athletes that's because the u.s
is participating in that diplomatic
boycott you mentioned earlier but the
real games are playing out in eastern
europe where russia the u.s and nato are
all fighting for influence
in a precise and very public performance
russian and belarusian forces move in
formation across frozen fields just
north of the ukrainian border
a military dress rehearsal for an
opening night that may or may not come
american officials say they do not
believe russian president vladimir putin
has decided if he will move against
ukraine
but a full-scale invasion would likely
begin with air strikes and long-range
artillery followed by airborne and
armored advances on several fronts
but putin is unlikely to launch an
invasion during the winter olympics
where he is one of the few world leaders
in attendance his high profile meeting
with chinese president xi jinping ended
in a joint statement that included one
of putin's key demands an end to nato
expansion
we
strongly prefer that russia choose the
path of diplomacy and dialogue
but if it does not we are fully prepared
for the for the alternative meanwhile
secretary of state anthony blinken met
with his polish counterpart as american
forces are expected to arrive in poland
as soon as this weekend and 8 200
additional troops are on standby to
reinforce nato allies
should rush it aside to put on more than
just a show
now american officials are estimating
that if russia does invade it could mean
up to a hundred thousand civilian
casualties and up to five million
refugees however so far both russia and
the u.s are saying they're still willing
to pursue diplomacy jeff
christina thank you they know